as warnings of snow and ice cover much
of the UK the dangers are clear to see
in the Pitch Black in Somerset this
morning a double decker bus carrying
workers to Hinckley Point C crashed onto
its side with 71 on board and a major
incident declared I Heard lots of
banging crashing screaming shouting So
that obviously woke me about 6 a.m and
took me a little while to sort of
realize I I had a feeling what happened
um looked at the windows lots of
Emergency Services on scene quite
quickly from what I can gather
there were no fatalities in this crash
which involved a motorcyclist but dozens
were injured
for any of these patients have
life-threatening injuries however 26
patients are being treated as walking
wounded
there are personal belongings of those
on board strewn across the road beside
this double decker bus a significant
investigation is now underway to uncover
just how this happened on a stretch of
road that locals say can be hazardous
this crash just one of more than 100
motoring incidents reported to Avon and
Somerset police on Monday night but the
dangerous weather conditions were felt
across the country
on the A6 in Northern Ireland drivers
faced blizzard conditions while in Essex
firefighters rescued a woman after her
car became trapped in flood water we've
seen a huge surge a number of breakdowns
through the course of today and in fact
we expect to end the day assisting more
drivers than we did yesterday now that's
unusual flat batteries by Far and Away
the biggest reason for our Patrol is
going out to people over the course of
the next few days and really what we're
seeing is the cold weather drives out
those kind of issues if there's existing
problems with cars the cold weather
tends to find those out and bring them
out to the front and sadly as a result
the cost of living crisis many drivers
aren't able to maintain their vehicles
to the same standards
there is more to come the Met Office has
issued snow and ice warnings across
parts of England and much of Scotland
Wales and Northern Ireland well into
Wednesday the advice for motorists if
you must travel take extreme care
Dan Whitehead Sky News in Somerset